good welcome to the wicked shadows
you know we've been around for hundreds
of years we know how to rock that's
right we know how to rock hard so yeah
yeah let me get ready for this are you
ready for this mate i'm ready for that
samurai we're up until 6am last night so
we're going to
hey guys what's up welcome to behind the
scenes for the order 1886. sorry the
order 1986. 1886 of the game 1986 is our
video
uh we're going to talk about how we made
the video the crazy ideas that went into
it or also do a little bit of comparing
and contrasting because uh sony actually
launched this thing called the order
dynamic hub and we've actually been
using this for a bunch of reference for
the piece for how to match our video to
the game and also how not to match your
video to the game because obviously we
have an 80s metal band and that is not
what the game is about
uh sam could you access the
internet
hold on
all right it's up we're online okay so
we imagine the characters of the game as
band members in this and galahad's kind
of the main guy so we made him the lead
singer and then first of all apparently
he's like the obi-wan kenobi the group
so that's like the guitars right the
guitarist is always the wisest member of
the band what's more trendy than having
a female drummer in your band so that's
lady ukraine and lafayette he doesn't
like he didn't get a serve next to his
name he's just lafayette so he figured
he's the goofy bass player the uh sonia
made a hyper detailed costume and they
sent it to us for the shoot
and that's why you read the warning
labels children we kind of mix and match
it with like acid wash jeans and like
high top sneakers for the 80s look
[Music]
yeah
black water is a blessing and a curse
it provides
life
and death
oh yes that's like the the black water
that keeps you alive forever like they
just keep drinking that so they live for
100 years like galahad's 100 years old
or something like that
really yeah what's it taste like who
makes it how much it's cost
do you still make it it's just a
gatorade the son of king arthur no son
yes no galahad is like literally knights
of the round table it's actually been to
merlin's grave it's a real thing
do you cast a spell uh i feel like an
acorn knot merlin wish me luck fireball
there's the the order the band from 1986
walks into the club called the warehouse
the warehouse is a werewolf one of the
things that we were quickly made aware
of is that there aren't actually
werewolves in the games they're lichens
or hatreds and so we're like well that's
the joke i guess
liking it too
in in our music video we have when it's
in the music video space and we're
getting it all wrong we have werewolves
just dudes and contacts and paint on
they're wearing earrings and stuff um
and then for the rest of the piece
you know we got this like uh staged
fight where a real lichen appears you
notice makeup's way different like the
guy playing the lykan is brandon he
played captain america in the heroes
video kill hitler and he sat in the
makeup chair for like six hours while
trista and her team
just covered him with prosthetics and
makeup like they had prosthetic muscles
that all the hair to do and he had to
actually paint everything also they put
contacts in anyways big props to trista
and our team for the makeup and big
props to john and manzy for putting
together the awesome costumes uh there's
a ton of crazy work that went into that
you hit the band you had the goons you
had the real liking and then of course
all the crew from the video is actually
in the video when we show the crew for
the video we had to make everybody look
a little more 80s so john had a best
song so what are you looking at butthead
do you look at these guns oh yeah those
are the guns we had in the in the video
itself for this video is pretty sweet
because the day before the shoot three
huge crates arrived straight up wooden
crates straight up wooden crates in fact
one wooden crate was busted because the
gun busted through the box and uh
there's these amazing intricate detailed
uh props and like these like thermite
rifles and like repeater guns and it was
insane it's probably the thermite rifle
isn't just like a gun apparently like
shoots like pellets of like flammable
gas or whatever
and then you shoot like a flare and that
flies into it and lights it all on fire
increasing bursts of flame so we need to
get a song made for this video and uh
this guy named max max norlick is the
guy who
has basically engineered and played all
the guitar and drums and all kind of
stuff for this song basically jake put
together a basic riff and a good idea of
where was going wrote some basic lyrics
throughout to max
and max put all the rest of it together
and we have the full song if you guys
want to download it and listen to it
like the solo is smoking hot so for
those of you who watch the channel you
probably know how we do a huge variety
of videos and this is kind of our first
foray into 80s music video style to
reach out to our friend jan who works a
lot with mike diva and if anybody knows
how to light things all colorful like
the 80s it would probably be jam
and so he set up a bunch of sweet lights
and we shot our new red epic dragon
it has way better low light sensitivity
has a ton of range perfect color
accuracy
um so you guys can expect our videos to
look way more hipster
it's a duct tape a sausage to the camera
thanks for watching i hope you liked the
video and behind the scenes in rare
village be able to grab all these
talented people and put them together in
one scene big thanks to sony for
sponsoring the video and letting us put
this together
alright guys if you have any questions
tweet them comment them uh write it down
on a paper and tie it to a bird's leg
and have it fly to us oh that works too
yeah or follow us on snapchat
i'm sorry i like literally have no idea